what's going on people it's Jake and
welcome back to another Elden ring
discussion video today I'd like to talk
about Melania and why she would have
been provoked into attacking us right
away I wanted to have this discussion
because I've always found it strange
that even if we know the location of
Michela in mogwan's Palace we still
aren't given the option to at least tell
Melania this information she had been in
a deep sleep here at the base of the
Halo tree since her Soldier brought her
back here after her battle against Redan
so you think this information would have
been well received by her and all of
Nicholas followers who have been looking
for him whether we know this information
or Not by the time we enter the halog
tree we are attacked by everyone and
everything without any hesitation in
fact we are attacked by pretty much
everything throughout the lands between
with the exception of a very small few
but even those few know exactly what and
who we are just by looking at us oh yeah
yes
tarnished are we come to the lands
between for the Elden ring hmm you're a
tarnished
I can see it
and I can also see
that you're not after my throat
a pleasure to meet the tarnished I am
the witch Rena I'd heard tale of a
tarnished hurting about Atop A spectral
steed
fell tarnished
what do you want I told the old hearing
brute that I possess no such Medallion
that Thug made off with a precious
necklace
I need someone to retrieve it only
he too is tarnished no
no but the help is very much appreciated
even from a tarnished despite
appearances nobility is no prerequisite
to serving the true order I think these
examples make it apparent that no matter
where you are from in the lands between
or what groups you're a part of being a
tarnish isn't exactly a secret it's
widely known that the greater will has
brought us back to the lands between as
a last resort to mend the Elden ring
back together some support you in this
cause some try to take advantage of you
but most don't even think it's possible
for you to do so so why not try to stop
you you're trying to take a powerful
great room from one of their leaders
like godric soldiers and Market trying
to stop you from entering Stormville or
radon's followers allowing you to fight
him to obtain his great Rune even though
they're likely just seeing it as an
excuse to see some Champions die in
battle against their once great leader
I'm sure this isn't the first Festival
that's been held at Red main Castle
which means Champions have failed time
and time again until you finally put
radon to rest no one really believes
that our journey is something actually
possible to complete but our reason for
living is only possible because the
guidance of Grace has allowed it our
initial purpose is solidified by Enya
and the two fingers of the Roundtable
hold
has long renounced the demigods
tarnished show no mercy at their heads
take all they have left indeed
this is pretty clear cut and dry
instructions from the greater will do
what it takes to retrieve as many great
runes as possible to mend the Eldon ring
as we know we don't need all of the
great runes to complete this goal only
two are required so getting more great
runes would depend on the particular
tarnished I hesitate to use the word
greed but if only two are necessary to
mend the Alden ring obtaining the rest
seems unnecessary unless that tarnish
just wants to acquire more power just
like the demigods themselves did
starting the shattering War now it isn't
known how public these exact
instructions by the two fingers are but
like I said it seems like everyone else
already knows so this gives us a good
enough reason for Melania to attack us
on site he would know that we are there
to obtain her and possibly nikola's
great room this would obviously be at
the disadvantage of the imperian Twins
and as the blade of mikola he is the
best equipped to stop us or at least she
was as I do believe Melania at this
moment when we find her is struggling
physically and mentally the physical
struggles are obvious she's lost most of
her limbs that needed to be replaced
with unalloyed gold Prosthetics and the
Scarlet rot has spread to her eyes which
are completely covered meaning she has
lost all Vision this is most likely the
reason that melania's movements are so
sporadic at least in regards to her
waterfowl dance she wildly swings her
sword around herself creating a sort of
bubble that makes it extremely difficult
to dodge while her movements are still
beautiful and somewhat calculated it's
not a stretch to cause some of her
movements random or without Precision
because she can't exactly pinpoint where
we are now the tragedy of melania's
story is that she is in a state of
suffering sleeping and waiting for her
brother to return to her as she
continues to rot away it also also seems
like her pride and ego are damaged she
doesn't want to be the goddess of rot
makes it very clear what she wants to be
the blade of mikola of course we get
annoyed at how many times she tells us
this as we most likely die to her many
times over she will say the same thing
that she is Melania blade of mikola now
this might be a bit of a stretch but
someone who is actually prideful or
proud of who they are doesn't have to
voice that to the world over and over
again they don't have to State the fact
that they've never been defeated they
would simply just take pride in that
fact and let their reputation speak for
itself but it seems like Melania has
lost that pride in herself and is
actively trying to convince herself that
she doesn't need the power of the rot
and that she is powerful enough as she
is there is something I must return to
Melania
the dignity
a sense of self that allowed her to
resist the call of the Scarlet rot The
Pride she abandoned to meet rodan's
measure it could be possible that
Melania is suffering from some sort of
delusion or delirium and she has to keep
mentioning that she is Melania blade of
mikola she has to keep telling herself
that she has never been defeated even
though the argument can be made that she
was defeated and had to resort to
something Beyond herself in the battle
with radon this is Millicent mentions
she had to resort to the power that is
slowly killing her and now who slow that
Growing Power of the rot she has to
convince herself that she doesn't need
it or it never even happened in short
she has basically lost her mind and
needs to convince herself that she is
powerful enough on her own so when we
come walking in he sees it as another
opportunity to prove to herself and to
the rot growing inside of her brain that
she is Melania blade of mikola now I
would love it if it were possible to
talk to Melania at some point possibly
having the option between phase one and
two you tell her where Michela is
located if we had gone to mowgwin's
Palace before meeting her in the halog
tree and you guys seem to feel the same
as almost 90 percent of 15 000 votes
agreed that this hypothetical
interaction with Melania would have been
interesting and made sense now some of
you mentioned that yes it would have
been awesome but if we could do this
that'd be too happy of an ending to the
questline rumsoft loves to make us cry
and needs a sad ending to every friendly
character we meet in all of their games
now I completely agree with this but I
don't think this interaction would lead
to a happy ending could you imagine how
Melania would react to seeing mikola
like this
probably not too well considering she's
already in a pretty fragile state of
mind it would just be so interesting to
at least have the choice to tell her
mikla's location if we know it or just
kill her in between faces and if we
choose to kill her she would become the
goddess of brought and it ends up being
a permanent choice so when you go back
to fighter if you die she'll just
transition from her first phase to the
second without the choice maybe just
having this knowledge of Michela could
have resulted in a different cut scene
But ultimately the same outcome just
like with Sif and artorius in Dark Souls
1 while it led to the same outcome it
gave a completely new meaning and tone
to the fight it was so tragically sad
now I'm not complaining about what we
got by any means just bringing up some
potential possibilities and who knows
maybe all of this will be possible in
the DLC because it does have some
serious implications toward time travel
and we know it's potentially possible
because of our fight with the dragonlord
man I really can't wait for DLC to come
out I hope the release date is at least
announced at summer game Fest this year
even though I'm almost positive we won't
see DLC until next year at some point
I'll be reacting to it live over on
Twitch so go drop a follow and come hang
out there if you want to that's all for
today's video thanks for watching and
I'll see you guys in the next one take
care